how to make less risky decisions why
don't more people pursue a life of
freedom and independence I don't think
it's because they're lazy or at least
most of them most likely it's because
they don't know how they believe it's
too hard or too risky they're scared
they don't know a clear path with
specific step-by-step actions but the
truth is most career in life
opportunities or at least the ones worth
taking involve some measure of chance
what if there was an opportunity that
wasn't a sure thing but has an extremely
high chance of success if the odds of
success in any attractive endeavor were
one hundred percent of course you'd step
up and pursue it without even stopping
to think and if the odds of success were
99 percent 95% nor even eighty-five
percent you probably would too
conversely if the odds of success were
meager only two percent or ten percent
you probably say no thanks just as
quickly it's when the odds of successive
between very unlikely and close to a
sure thing that matters get complicated
everyone's risk tolerance is different
but we all have some range where we'd
have to think long and hard before
pursuing an opportunity or making a
career decision short of a crystal ball
the only solution to this problem is to
become a better risk assessor this isn't
as difficult as it sounds just keep two
principles in mind when considering any
big decision identify the hazards and
don't make decisions based on the fear
of missing out step one identify the
hazards if you're the worrying type
here's one time where the tendency to
worry can help you even if you're not
take a few minutes to list out
everything that can go wrong with any
potential change risk or opportunity in
many cases you'll discover that the
worst possible hazards are neither
life-threatening nor likely to occur
even when the stakes are high and the
consequences are substantial just
knowing what's out there can give you
confidence to proceed or the wisdom to
back away if it really
is too risky step number two don't make
decisions based on the fear of missing
out because we tend to make decisions
based on fear or perceive scarcity you
sometimes feel pushed into a less than
ideal course of action the more we can
make rational decisions based on the
information currently available to us
the better will become at assessing risk
that's how you make less risky decisions
you